bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rtl france alors vous êtes à
beyrouth ont dit que le calme est revenu
à calais à l'atmosphère actuelle
et si les choses reviennent vitocal
montrer ce genre d'événement beyrouth
enfin il ya un calme très précaire mais
il ya
ce qui est très important c'est qu'il ya
une énorme inquiétude aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas nouvelle vous avez dit dans
votre introduction juste avant le
reportage ça s'est passé dans lequel
alors que le pays fait face à une crise
multiforme ce qui s'est passé hier n'est
que qu'une des manifestations de cette
crise n'est pas un événement isolé de ce
par quoi passe le pays
alors on va contextualiser en ce qui
s'est passé hier pour vraiment
comprendre il y avait donc un
rassemblement appelé par les mouvements
hesbollah yamal qui manifestement a
rapidement dégénéré mais aujourd'hui on
ne sait toujours pas qui a tiré
donc
oui bien sûr je pense qu'il est
intéressant pour les gens de
concessionnalité de comprendre ce qui
s'est effectivement passé aujourd'hui
malheureusement je suis en mesure de
rapporter ces réponses là ce que je sais
c'est que ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que dans le cadre c'est-à-dire que quand
on nous sommes nous sommes gouvernés par
des tribus confessionnelles qui ont
perdu le l'élément qui servait à
monnayer le système et regarder à
conserver la paix civile quand quand
l'argent a disparu et qu'on a réalisé
que font pas seulement les caisses
étaient vides mais que le système s'auto
détruisent et et donc il n'y avait plus
les ressources pour qu'il le puisse se
perpétuer et bien il s'est passé deux
choses j'en parlais il ya quelques
semaines à votre antenne d'ailleurs deux
heures on pousse les libanais à immigrer
donc on vide le pays de toute sa classe
moyenne d'une part d'une autre part il
reste que les miséreux dans le pays est
bien pour faire accepter aux miséreux la
situation dans la situation impossible
dans laquelle on aimait et bien quand la
rétention arrive à leur comble
eh bien ça se traduit par des
affrontements comme ça pour rappeler
tout le monde au calme et dire nous
sommes nous c'est nous qui conservons la
paix civile nous décidons quand ça
commence nous décidons quand
sainte-hermine exister juste une
encore une fois une démonstration
de l'incapacité de l'absolu incapacité
des chefs de guerre confessionnelle et
des et de ceux qui ont de ceux qui ont
financé ce système les milliardaires qui
ont monté les banques et ces fonds
auraient envahi de gérer quoi que ce
soit sur le terrain donc
c'est je pense à le plus important donc
après on va parler d'eux on va lier ça
la question du
de l'enquète du port on va essayer de
savoir d'ailleurs juste voudraient
ajouter il ya pas seulement des
ministres des ministres chikhi sont
inculpées dans cette affaire il ya un
ministre sunnite il ya un ministre
maronite donc comme d'habitude dans le
système libanais est en fait bien
l'équilibré entre entre entre toutes les
factions donc ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de problème à ce niveau-là mais encore
une fois cette question là n'est qu'un
n'est qu'une question de façade
c'est lié cet événement simplement à
l'histoire de l'explosion du port et de
l' enquête et s'est fait rare et ne va
voir comment les choses au liban sont
toutes connectées entre elles et le fait
que la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans le pays ne peut
mener qu'à des situations comme celle
que nous allons nous avons vu hier s'est
immiscé situation iront crescendo il y a
nécessairement un besoin de que ceux qui
sont prêts à prendre leurs
responsabilités dans ce pays entame et
puis un changement fondamental il faut
pas jouer trop d'ailleurs de jeter un
dernier mot il faut pas oublier que les
chefs de guerre confessionnelle
aujourd'hui au pouvoir sont ceux qui
sont restés parce que ceux qui ont
commencé la guerre sont morts ceux qui
ont commencé la guerre ne sont plus ils
ont été assassinés le liban est bien
connu pour ça ceux là sont ceux qui ont
qui sont restés à la fin de la guerre
aujourd'hui ils ont évité au pays la
guerre civile
autant que possible tant que ça les
garder certainement que c'est légal de
pouvoir aujourd'hui ils doivent réaliser
qu'ils sont incapables de gérer la
situation il est temps pour eux de
passer la main un gouvernement capable
de gérer une crise énorme parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les outils pour ça est ce que
vous redoutez une nouvelle escalade de
violence qu'est ce que est ce que vous
redoutez le pire au liban
oui déjà j'évite le pays se vide un lieu
encore une fois il ya qu'il ya quelques
semaines on parle de
parler votre antenne des chiffres que
nous sommes en train de parler de
l'immigration de d'un demi million à 2
millions de tonnes à 1 million de
libanais d'accord ce qui représente à
peu près 25% de la population sur place
donc quand on parle un peu de grand
remplacement en france mon groupe est
bien sûr que si j'étais face c'est
j'aurais pas été aussi inquiets en
voyant ce qui se passe au liban le il y
à une destruction systématique de la
société qui est en train qui est en
train de prendre place aujourd'hui il le
restera encore une fois dans ce dans ce
pays que les miséreux qui serviront de
chair à canon c'est la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes et encore une fois
ce n'est pas le résultat enfin tout tout
ce qui se passe par là la question de la
question de l' enquête la question de
l'explosion on va parler de
l'intervention étrangère et à tout ça ce
ne sont que des excuses pour faire en
sorte de rappeler à la situation qui est
à la population va compliquer au quilit
qui est aux commandes et faire en sorte
que les gens acceptent la situation
terrible dans laquelle ils sont mais je
pense que la situation est
suffisamment mauvaises qu'aujourd'hui
ces gens là devraient être inquiet des
gens qui sont les jeux par des chefs
professionnels je devrais être inquiet
des gens qui n'en touche parce que la
situation qui leur font vivre et
tellement été tellement difficile qui
risquent de retrouver de finir par
trouver le même le même sort que ceux
des chefs qui ont des chefs
communautaires qui ont commencé la
guerre civile en 75 et qui ne sont plus
puisqu'ils ont été éliminés parfois par
des gens très proches de mounir duman et
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle qu'on vous êtes
membre du parti de libanais citoyens et
citoyennes dans un état